area 15 is back with another way to
celebrate the season
safely and with a twist you get a free
hot chocolate with your ticket purchase
rocky theis escape to wonderland kind of
show us around
[Music]
we have entered wonderland here at area
15 this is a great place
to celebrate the holidays chris director
of cool stuff here
absolutely at night especially when the
lights are off all the trees are
flashing
music's pumping and you got your holiday
spirit but with a twist
every so often you might see our kind of
an elf it's a good example
yes instead of elves here at area 15
they have aliens and they look
really happy to be here yeah don't be
confused by the deadpan look that's a
he's jumping for joy right now they just
don't have the same
level of excitement here's an art car
called mr fusion
by the artist henry chang we have a
couple of these around this is our
version of the sleigh
uh you know santa sleigh but it's got a
fusion motor
to really get that extra speed that you
need especially
but nowadays course this is an
instagramable moment absolutely lots of
instagramable moments with
rudolph the red-nosed alien and all
around inside the
snow globes you can go in and uh kind of
create your own
version of a postcard moment here's a
good one here
oh i love it oh snow globe this is so
perfect especially as we have to social
distance we get our own little bubble
you get your own bubble and this is kind
of the party bubble it looks like
they've been partying all night actually
let's go hang out let's go hang out with
these guys they probably need a little
pep talk
yeah they look like they had way too
much fun yet don't worry you'll get a
second win
stay in there stick in stick in there
buddy oh man
so area 15 hot for the holidays how can
people celebrate with you guys well you
go to area15.com
20 tickets spread out but order your
tickets and uh come join us here
i love it well i'm having the time of
our life i'm trying to be on their level
so let's go ahead and take our selfie
let's do it let's take our selfie right
[Music]
now
that's a great picture rocky